previously on model lifestyle so finally
I came back to Nikita
after three months and every time when
you come back home you see just how much
you have missed out on so while my
mother agency is looking into the
options for my next modeling contract I
spend my time with family but I also had
to catch up on my responsibilities at
home like working in the garden finally
the day came when I could decide on
where I would go for my next modeling
contract okay I think I'll choose hi if
this is your first time on my channel
subscribe and hit the bell so you won't
miss the next video
[Music]
finally the day came when my mother
agency called me with the options for my
next modeling contract so I can either
go to Malaysia or Cape Town that's the
best for right now yeah I think I'll
choose Cape Town to make it as well few
days later I was boarding a flight to
Cape Town I waved goodbye to Nikita
knowing I will miss her a lot but I have
to go so that we can get money to pay
for her college house and everything
else
I will be responsible
[Music]
[Music]
the flood was super quick and I arrived
in Cape Town
[Music]
I picked up my bags and decided to take
uber to my new model apartment but when
I got into the car the driver started
telling me about the water crisis in
Cape Town so I just arrived in South
Africa Cape Town and there's a water
problem here it's quite rough it's a
it's a crisis that they are in and
people are complaining because the
politicians are playing these games
between the political parties like the
ANC India India if they just want
solutions they just want to take things
to be fixed if this is gonna go on for
too long it's gonna be a very very very
big what is like people are going today
giving water broke up water cut
how are those kids gonna survive we need
to any crisis we don't know what about
if it's not gonna rain next it this is I
kept on telling people like save water
save water okay it's cool saving water
what innovative projects are you guys
doing analyze are the ANC the national
governments they are responsibilities
now why are they saying the national
government in the moment when captain is
flourishing and things are going on
where people talk at the GS doing good
but now because these water crisis now
they're putting the you see that is like
it's like a kindergarten children
fighting exactly but it's not we don't
want that nothing
what we want is water I don't care DNC I
don't care coke for whatever you need
water
so this is here which one is the left
waist a number on the right side
yeah ah this one my model apartment for
the next two months cool I got my own
bathroom I left my bags in the room and
I decided to go down to the beach I've
heard it by the water crisis and now I
just want to go down to the beach and
see how that looks like and then I see
this right here something dangerous they
happen here somebody died over here the
first day in Cape Town it's not looking
so good let me tell you a little bit
about cape town cape town holds an
estimated population of 3.8 million
people and it was appointed the best
place in the world to visit by the New
York Times in 2014 now the weather here
is very similar to California and a
Mediterranean summer season starts from
November to March and this is a great
time for modeling in Cape Town because a
lot of clients come here from Europe to
do their photo shoots and TV commercials
later today I had my first experience of
taking a shower while trying to save
water now everyone in Cape Town does it
the same way you put a bucket underneath
you and open the water for just a little
bit to make you wet and to rinse off the
soap then you use the same bucket to
flush the toilet
[Music]
the weekend passed away quick and Monday
came and it was time to go to my agency
and pick up my model carts which I would
need for the castings but on my way
there I noticed all the homeless people
and my heart just went out to them
I wondered why are they homeless what
happened with their lives
drugs accidents family what the world
that we live in can sometimes be tough
sometimes we cannot choose what happens
to us but we can choose how we react to
it that is a hard lesson that I learned
anyway I finally arrived at night
[Music]
[Applause]
hey guys oh good good good are you
[Applause]
I picked up my cart and was ready for
when the castings would come
[Music]
not my way back I saw yet another crime
scene what is going on here in Kate time
maybe this is normal for the people here
and I got used to other countries that
is safer I haven't been here in Cape
Town for the last five years so maybe I
just forgot a bit anyway time flew by
and I did not even get one casting or
job I started to wonder if this was the
result of the water crisis anyway on
Sunday I decided to go check out a
church near the model apartment it is
called Life Church
it had an amazing and peaceful
atmosphere
[Applause]
after the service the pastor invited me
to go with him to the poor area of Cape
Town to see the project that they have
there to help the kids who are in need
this is a solo okay a lot of the time
those two communities the gangsters
flesh
each other so no cheating yeah Samora
was getting electricity cassava wasn't
and they thought that Samora was fully
painted from the government or something
when I started getting fried such a
mighty years ago
yeah now the local governments Law
Institute from Walter
see
and man my heart just went out to these
kids
[Music]
so you guys try to defeat about a
thousand kids everyday who feed and
educate about the conservative stuff
so here we've got our main Krrish down
space here's about 30 kids and from here
we facilitates and teach the other
creatures on what they should be doing
stay on in the house within their
capacity
that's all basically foster parent
student
love them getting attention to come in
and I'm Brandon at nine
yeah so these kids are staying in this
place are all kids has been abandoned
and before we leave it's it's often
involved inaudible children so in South
Africa in order to be classified orphan
you only have one parent then the other
one just is basically non active
vulnerable is a child that's in any
distress the environment way it is an
abusive parents alcoholic Pearman parent
drug abuse
and so we identify those through social
workers
an ability to you then we bring them
into the
we are need a lot of hold into six
months while the Pens
immersed or they
seeing those kids and what they face
every day made me really angry and sad
at the same time and I mean what kind of
person are you if you can easily abandon
your own child anyway the modeling
season in Cape Town seemed to have
stopped and I'm not getting any work but
instead of just sitting and waiting I
decided to use the time to explore Cape
Town and I went everywhere
I even thought about cage diving with
sharks but I did not want to die yet
what a bad idea
I also have time to catch up with some
old friends like Chris I met him in
Japan while he worked for the same
modeling agency there I also to spend
time with new friends that I made here
like Darren Darren also helped me to
report one of the male model workout
videos from my channel it looks like
this
[Music]
and when we were done with the video we
just walked along the beach and shared
allies
[Music]
finally just as I thought that the
modeling season in Cape Town will be bad
I got my first cast
[Music]
so I went early and I took the my city
bus
I was super excited
but I was not ready for what I was about
to experience
[Music]
hi if this is your first time on my
channel subscribe and hit the bell so
you won't miss the next video
[Music]